last time we looked at areas under
curves and we had a look at areas that
you had to consider it as different
parts right if you remember the reason
why we had to consider miss different
parts of just do a rough one here is
because you had different parts of the
area for example it might have been
above or below the axis do you remember
that cuz integration and this is
actually going to become enormously
useful for isolate this lesson
integration takes into the count takes
into account the fact that this area is
believe the answers so it gives you back
it will return a negative number right
so therefore if what I actually want is
just a lot of space is it you have to
look at this negative say oh I don't
actually want it to be negative I want
to start a minus sign on that so I get a
positive positive positive that gives
you a total area okay so therefore we
consider an area like this as two
integrals we do this little part here
and then we will do this part and we
treat them separately okay we call this
integrating over separate intervals
right so you'd maybe go from negative 1
to 0 there's your first interval and
then you go from 0 to 1 and you treat
them separately okay now in a similar
way we're going to look today at on
different kinds of areas that we also
need to consider as through different
pieces but for a different reason okay
for more obvious reasons because you've
got multiple curves flying around okay
so this is just one curve but it crosses
the answers this is what you've actually
got two different graphs and we want to
work out how they interplay together so
here's our first example the area are
interested in is this one underneath the
curve okay so it's one little melded
area I'm going to color it in second so
to you but the reason I haven't colored
it just yet is because even though it's
one little bounded area it really is
actually two separate pieces that I'm
going to consider separately okay so you
can see there's a point of intersection
here right and help to the left of this
line the left of this line this area you
you can see it this is the area beneath
what curve which cousin
yeah good it's underneath this code in
fact that area I just shaded blue has
nothing to do with the second curve at
least in terms of what wine is
underneath does have something to do
with that that boundary there but apart
from that number nobody apart from that
number is completely independent of this
graph ok conversely when you never look
at the second half there i'm going to
show you this in a different color this
green area has nothing to do with y
equals x squared it's not touching that
graph at all in fact you could delete
off while it goes x square that green
area you can still define it very easily
ok so blue green i'm going to call this
one very originally area one we gonna
call this one error two how do i work
out with this areas and its boundaries
don't i right i need an upper bound and
a lower bound the lower bounds really
easy the law about it's just you right
hey how do I determine the other bound
ok so you've got some symmetry happening
here right so you know the district over
here good morning is to write so I
actually can make a surgery on you and
say well that should be right in the
middle however I'm not actually going to
do that in this case because well
they're not often like that you'll get
completely different graphs that have no
kind of symmetry you can take advantage
on this point up here that defines the
upper bound is really the point of
intersection between these two graphs ok
so therefore i'm just going to solve for
when this graph intersects is our it's
not too complicated ok so let's pretty
quick and do that I don't even like what
I'm doing the point of intersection is
when x squared is equal to X minus 20
square so if we quickly expand this out
and there's that number that you already
expecting because it is indeed halfway
between 0 & 2 ok so now I know this has
an x value by the way a bit annoying in
the acid point of intersection I
actually don't need to know the Y value
right why not yeah very good when i'm
integrating i'm integrating with respect
to the x-axis so all I need are the X
boundaries ok so 0 to 1 double duty
right now I'm ready to form my integral
I'll do the first area what the first
area like we said is underneath x
squared so I integrate from naught to
one there are my boundaries x squared DX
simple is it not complicated ok so what
I need to know is the primitive function
of x squared the primitive of x squared
is X Q entreat very good I know from
experience you're probably going to be
still a little bit in man am I
differentiating of her is a grating vote
can I encourage you in these it's still
fairly early on in terms of our
understanding of integration they just
mentally checked every time you do this
just go back and differentiate right
make sure you haven't accidentally
differentiated from kita here it's a
very bless you common error okay great
so now I've got my upper lower
boundaries that's a third take away 0 so
there's my first area okay now keeping
in mind this symmetry that we were
expecting before I kind of have a guess
as to what a 2 is but I don't have like
it's not actually an even odd function
or if you like that so I don't have any
explicit symmetry I can take advantage
on in those terms so I'm just going to
evaluate the integral right what
integral should I write my boundaries
once it's me very good and I'm going to
be doing X minus 2 or swear okay now at
this point you have choice you can
expand this thing I already know what
it's going to expand out to and then you
can integrate terms one by one so
there's three
pretty manageable okay however I don't
have to expand I don't have to expand
and it's in my interest to practice
integrating this without expanding just
in case you know a question is a bit
prickly and they give me a power that I
cannot expand that it's not practical to
do this is just as easy to integrate
using a reverse chain rule as this is if
I careful with it okay now let me help
you I'm going to give you a bit of a tip
for user your best trainer because like
I said it takes a bit of a mind shift
we're pretty good at just doing it with
um with an X term it's by itself but
what we see is it gets a bit confusing
okay so here's what I remember there's a
power to do that so I think we all know
that this is coming from something which
has a power of three so that's going to
be the primitive okay now if I had this
right if I was differentiating that what
would I get ya the three would come out
front very good and then the power would
reduce by one okay so this is 3
something squared and we really used to
seeing it's because you've been
differentiating for so long if you saw
something like this okay again you
familiar with the pattern of the power
comes out the front and the power
reduces by one really really familiar
with that okay so something you can do
here to compensate is to say well after
[ __ ] there there's kind of a number
missing right there's the number that's
bigger by one you see that there's no
bar speaker by one there's no math
figure by one okay so here's what i'll
do i'll have that integral still there
and i'll put the missing number there
three okay so this came from something
cute but of course you can't just put in
numbers because you like to put your
numbers to make things easier to
integrate so in order to compensate for
that 3 i'm going to put a one-third out
the front so you can see this is kind of
like the same thing we do with
rationalizing into nominator you
multiply and divide by the same number
okay and this compensates this makes
this in this easy form that I'm good at
recognizing okay and if it was a
different power i would multiply or
divide by a different number okay so
once I've got this that inferred that
just hangs out the front and now I'm
ready to state the primitive function
right is three something squared so when
I integrate up what did I differentiate
from the answer is something cubed
that's all okay so there you go more
complicated just an idea to help you if
you don't find that helpful then don't
worry about it but I do find that as
these guys in the middle get more and
more complicated this compensating idea
becomes very very useful yeah what
happened if it was like to work okay
great that's a great idea so for example
if I'd started with this let's just
measure that good morning if I was
starting with this okay I think two
things number one that's going to have
to be a three that's where it came from
okay so I'm expecting a 3d be here but
because of the reverse chain rule right
this should also be a 2 a 3 a door to so
that's a six altogether right so I'm
expecting this right that's what I'm
expecting but of course I can't have a
because when I when I if I start a bit
if I started weird i'm running out of
space if i started with this 2x minus 1
cubed right i'm going to multiply by the
three that's four three i had before but
then I also multiplied by the two which
we give me six so that's the 6 i'm kind
of expecting but of course they want to
have success I've gotta compensate and
have the 16 out front so there's a net
change of 0 okay so this would work fine
this would be a 62 x minus one cute poss
constant because that's indefinite oh
you don't need the kinds of might become
I have multiplied in my 20 you see so
now again the reason I can I know this
issue is because just like I suggested
over here let's just take this guy and
differentiate him to be sure right so
that three will come out the front and
then the two also come out the front
both of which will cancel this one sixth
which will give me exactly what I
expected okay so differentiation is
going to be your acid test for did I get
the right integral or not and we
encourage you as much as possible
mentally check back then you lee check
back because
doing both at the same time you don't
get stuck in one mode you get used to
changing between them because you do
have to okay all right I think I'm ready
to integrate sorry I'm ready to evaluate
yeah so what am I going to get when I
evaluate at my upper bound yeah good
because I got two months to cube 0 what
happens when I evaluate at my lower
bound I get because i'm subtracting a
lower bound and of course minus 1 cubed
is minus 1 okay it's at all right see
how I got that that was 1-2 maybe one
group so there's my double maybe there's
one so there's the one third unit square
that I was expecting from before because
of this symmetry right I've run out of
space down to you but you know what to
do to finish this off right the total
area is a1 plus a2 that's two-thirds
square units okay you happy with that
you can see how crucial it was to form
my argument off of a diagram right you
see could be saving this yet your
diagram needs to be clear so you can see
where the point move to second is and
calculate it you're diagramming to be
big enough big enough backwards you can
divide it up into the different parts
and you can distinguish them okay and
you can also like make them and then use
that in your work here okay